I don't think we're yet to the point
that you have to you know keep an eye on
your Roomba for a sneak ambush or
something like that you know like death
by dust inhalation or something but I do
think there are some issues that we need
to pay attention to and so I actually
went around and interviewed all these
various robotic scientists and said you
know is this something that is a
possibility let's take this seriously
and there are basically three answers
one was know that silly it will not
happen these are systems for example
that don't have a survival instinct and
in all of science fiction the story is
always that the machine gets scared and
lashes out at the humans first well
guess what we're building these machines
specifically to die in war so why would
they care the second answer is don't
worry about it the software you know is
will probably crash right at the moment
that they're you know deciding to revolt
you know they'll try and load a ms word
document and boom just like what's
happening to all of us the third answer
though is a fascinating one is that
there is a pretty substantial minority
and it has a lot of distinguished people
in it who do think it's a possibility
someday one Pentagon scientist for
example said to me you know I'm probably
working on something that's either going
to kill or enslave my grandkids but you
know it's really cool stuff so why stop
right now we have 5,000 of these drones
in the air 12,000 on the ground if we
take the growth trajectory up as one air
force lieutenant general put it we're
reaching into the tens of thousands this
is the future of war but there is
another side of the future of war that
is the enemy has a vote and so you have
these continual global insurgencies and
that's these two trends coming together
both the unmanned of war but also the
flattening of war that is it's becoming
a game in which not just States play and
the challenge for all of us is that both
robotics and insurgencies and terrorism
are things that one we don't understand
very well and two we really haven't yet
figured out how to deal with them
you have these two trends coming
together and that's a challenge for us
all